hello everyone my name is michael key
i'm the
ceo of impello biosciences we're a
biostimulant
company located in northern colorado
and today we'll be talking about how we
can manipulate
environmental inputs in cannabis
cultivation to optimize genetic
expression
of that cannabis variety so that being
said it's a pretty
broad topic i'm not sure how familiar
everyone is with biostimulants but
they're kind of a subclass of
agricultural or horticultural inputs
and when we talk about or environmental
inputs as a whole of course there's a
lot of different
factors that we can manipulate
if you're in a controlled environment
you can obviously control a lot more of
those
variables than you can if you're let's
say growing outdoors in the field
but regardless of the environment and
the situation that you're in
focusing on your environmental inputs is
a very important way
that you can control and kind of dictate
your crops performance
so we'll get into all of that and how
they relate to biostimulants
but the four overarching ideas that i
will cover over the next 30 minutes
are as follows here so i like to
remind people and i always like to think
about
plants environment and its environmental
limitations
as opportunities and that's a unique
perspective to have
that were afforded only by working with
biostigmas
so to give an example in a
cannabis environment let's say
we're dealing with a soil type that may
be historically
you know subpar or not optimum for
cannabis cultivation
but maybe over seasons of growing we've
seen some really unique
plant phenotypes or really unique plant
flower qualities coming out of that
instead of looking at that soil now
simply as an environmental limitation
we can actually use biostimulant
technology and
and use our knowledge of the environment
to dive into that soil use sequencing
techniques
look at plants genetic expression or
search transcriptomic
expression it's metabolic expression to
actually understand
what characteristics or what aspects of
that soil
are providing some benefits and then
what's not providing benefits
um so instead of just looking at
something like a subpart
soil as an environmental limitation we
can actually start to exploit
the good aspects of it and then figure
out how to eliminate the bad aspects
uh that kind of plays directly into the
idea that biostimulants are a new
variable in crop cultivation
so historically we've had fertilizers
if you're growing inside or some some
people outside use carbon dioxide
injection as a way to
improve plant productivity of course we
can control irrigation
but biostimulants i look at as a new
variable
in a plant growth equation a biological
equation
so if you're adding a biostimulant
that's capable of promoting growth
through different mechanisms or in a
different way then a traditional
fertilizer or pesticide might be able to
we're actually increasing the
theoretical limit of plant productivity
that would otherwise be limited
simply or constrained by the types of
inputs that we're using
so using something like a biostimulant
will allow us to increase that that
theoretical
plant potential maximum and
actually achieve whether it's greater
yields or higher plant quality or both
achieve something that would otherwise
be unachievable by just using
traditional ag inputs
now again that funnels down into the
third overarching idea
here and that's that biostimulus not
only are a new variable and act in a new
way
but they do that on a scale that's
pretty atypical to
previous generations or iterations of
agricultural inputs and
what i mean by that is it has a whole
omic input or influence
i didn't create this term but it's
something that we experience a lot in my
company
so while we started we focused primarily
on the metabolomic
influence of different crop inputs being
in the cannabis industry
that's one of the easiest things to
focus on of course most
hemp or cannabis growers are testing for
secondary metabolites like cannabinoids
and terpenes
and looking at how the inputs that we
use are
influencing the production of those
metabolites is important
but we realized pretty early on that
these biostimulants are so powerful and
have such a
such an overarching influence on crop
performance
that not only are we influencing
metabolomics but logically we're
actually
can work backwards and say well we're
influencing the proteome
and before that we're influencing the
transcriptome and even on a genomic
level
uh these biostimulant inputs are having
an effect so again that plays into the
whole idea that a
crop's genetic potential is kind of the
basis
and then we can manipulate the
environment to have an influence from a
genomic level
to a transcriptomic level to a proteomic
level
and then ultimately also at the
metabolic level which is kind of the end
result that we see there
so those three ideas i think
encompass a lot of the technological
side of biostimulants and how we can
utilize them to optimize genetic
expression in plants
but they all also play into
a fundamentally important idea and
concept for us to all work with both in
agriculture and other
aspects of of global industry and that's
sustainability
um in today's day and age it
it's not a surprise that that i think
all new technologies should have some
focus on sustainability and
biostimulants play very nicely into that
we're working with a technology here
that
to some extent is an alternative
uh to genetic engineering of course
there's been some backlash in years
despite all the tremendous benefits that
genetic engineering has provided
the perception is not quite what it used
to be and
industry and consumers are actually
looking for alternatives
to genetic engineering solutions and
biostimulants
are you know a very viable option for
that
not only are they highly technical not
only can they achieve
a lot of things that genetic engineering
can and also some things genetic
engineering cannot
but they can do it in a very uh
sustainable
natural way by basically harnessing
natural potential nature's potential
things that are already occurring
in life and in biology
but we're developing the ideas we're
understanding the mechanisms in a way
that allows us to manipulate that better
and make greater progress by using these
sustainable technologies
have a big influence on crop
productivity so that being said
if we think about agriculture
um as a spectrum of ideals and and i
always like to say organic
farming organic agriculture is certainly
at one end of the spectrum
then conventional or intensive
agriculture would be at the other end of
the spectrum
um you know conventional you could say
is the platform of the spectrum and
organic is the white end of the spectrum
that being said those two groups don't
necessarily always agree
on their ideas um you know i think there
are a lot of people in the organic
or at the organic end of the spectrum
that are essentially opposed to any
conventional agricultural techniques
there are a lot of conventional
agriculturalists or farmers
who are not at all interested in
incorporating organic techniques
simply because of the negative stigma
and the kind of thought that
organic is nice but it's really
impractical
that's an old idea that's not something
that i think we should
carry on into the future and that's why
as simple as this looks i think
and as simple as this idea is i think
it's very important that
if we if we go along with that idea that
organic and conventional are
totally you know totally polar opposites
all the gray space in between that
should be looked at as a sustainability
aspect so we can take some of the best
aspects of organic farming
some of the best aspects of conventional
farming and combine them
in new materials and methods that
ultimately are more sustainable
both on the manufacturing side and also
on the production side
that's where biostimulants fall i think
it's
kind of a both a great characteristic
and a great opportunity of the
biosimulant industry to be able to play
in that middle ground
where we're not making
some organic farming and biostimulant
farming synonymous
but rather a biostimulant input can be
both organic
and conventional or it could be
conventional or organic i should say
and being a biostimulant farmer doesn't
necessarily mean that you're
subjecting yourself to only organic
practices or only conventional practices
rather than you're
focusing on sustainability you're
focusing on utilizing the best
technologies from both sides of the
spectrum all aspects of
all parts of the spectrum and by doing
so you're actually achieving something
much greater than
what you would if you were just at one
end or the other
select one ground rule i think another
ground rule to keep in mind
just as i'm going through this is the
idea and this is an equation people have
probably heard before
but that uh crop performance is
ultimately dictated or ultimately it
comes down to
a simple equation of genetics times
environment
i've also heard this described as
genotype by environment the idea being
that
you can have tremendous genetic
potential in a crop
you can have a beautiful environment
whether that's a controlled environment
or
or you know a greenhouse or just optimum
conditions out in a field
but you really need to have a
combination of both the genetics
and the crop environment for that crop
to perform
maximally or optimally that's
obviously the underlying idea of this
presentation but we're not going to
focus so much on the genetic
aspect of course as a biological input
company or about stimulant company we're
particularly concerned with the
environment
side but that doesn't mean that we
actually don't focus
quite a bit of our resources on the
genetic side we work really closely with
some
genetics manufacturers both industrial
varieties and high cbd horticultural
style crops
because we think it would be a
fundamental flaw to develop biological
products by stimulant products
any sort of environmental input without
closely considering the
genetics of the plant that we're
developing those inputs for
because they go so hand in hand you
can't really remove
one half of the equation and expect to
have
you know a full comprehensive solution
it doesn't work that way
we have to consider genetics even though
we're an input company
and likewise genetics company could
should consider what's possible
what an input company is capable of
producing
what farmers can actually use and
ultimately that will help make sure that
both the direction of genetic
progression and the direction of
biostimulant technologies
are working in a way that is productive
for everyone involved
now the last little ground rule that i
would like to lay
is uh kind of some background on
biostimulants so
i think for people who have been in
agriculture for a long time or who have
been in academia and studied
biostimulants or biological technologies
for years
will understand that we're not
in the infancy necessarily of
biostimulant technology
it's more appropriate to say we're maybe
toddlers
biostimulants have been researched for
two decades or more
of course they've gained a lot of
popularity in in the 2000s and
the 2010s excuse me
where we started to look for
alternatives to genetic engineering like
i said and we're
starting to really focus on how we can
increase crop productivity in ways that
we haven't been able to before
we've got these tremendous demands of
feeding 10 billion people by 2050
we have tremendous amounts of food waste
we grow a lot of food
we grow a lot of calories but that's
also led to problems of its own
so biostimulants fit into this nice you
know it's fortuitous timing to an extent
that there are cultural movements that
are encouraging the the research and the
development and the production and the
use of biosignals
but it's also important to consider that
there's huge
you know global demands that consumers
aren't necessarily thinking of but that
us as academics researchers industry
folks
need to consider and need to start
preparing um
for the future more or less so
that being said biostimulants of today
are not what they were 20 years ago
so i'll say something like yield is easy
and i don't necessarily mean that in
doubling or tripling or quintupling a
yield is easy it's not
what i do mean by that is 20 years ago
when we had our first bacterial isolate
products and our first biostimulants
there were a lot of claims made like we
would increase yields you know 10 or 15
or 25 percent
and you could replicate that in the lab
but you could never replicate that
elsewhere
we've come a long way over the last 20
years and actually most biostimulant
products i'll take
microbial uh plant growth promoting
bacteria for example
their development their technology is so
far
superior nowadays to what it was 20
years ago that it's actually not
surprising at all
when a farmer who's not using a
biostimulant or a microbial inoculant
incorporates that product for the first
time for them to see a 5
10 15 increase in yield particularly if
it's into a system that's never
had any sort of input like that before
there's a replenishing aspect
you know especially out in the field
environment where adding even something
as simple as a growth hormone bacteria
can have these tremendous effects
also can have tremendous effects on
fertilizer reduction
so we've seen farmers reduce fertilizer
rates by 10
20 25 30 in some cases
and without any yield loss that's not
necessarily the direction that
biostimulant technology
is now focused on i think that's hugely
important but biomass yield in and of
itself
is not necessarily the only direction
the only thing that
biostimulant manufacturers and farmers
need to be considering when they're
using these technologies
instead it's coming back to that genetic
potential and cannabis is a great
example of this because phenolics really
are the future
so when we're developing our
biostimulants at impello what we're
focused on doing
is finding biostimulant technology
microbial inoculants
that increase yield which should be
pretty easy
but also increase the yield of not just
biomass but let's say phenolic compounds
when we're growing cannabis that's
ultimately what we're growing cannabis
for and i think
other crops will start to revert back to
that
you know the idea that an apple a
hundred years ago had about five times
the nutritional value of an apple
today tells me that
we shouldn't necessarily just be focused
on growing more we should be focused on
growing better
instead of trying to grow five times
more apples into the future to feed the
whole world we can focus on
making each apple more nutritious it's a
lofty goal
but i don't think it's impossible
particularly considering the way that
biostimulants often work
and that's multiple modes of action so
being biological products being
living organisms being signaling
molecules that often
play multiple roles within a plant means
that we have multiple different
mechanisms that we can exploit out of
each technology
so for example tribus original is a
bacterial consortium that my company
makes
it's a tremendous growth promoting
bacteria because each
bacteria species that we incorporate is
fabulous at mobilizing nutrients
cellulizing potassium or mobilizing
phosphorus
fixing nitrogen even to an extent but
the benefits of a consortia or of adding
a consortium don't stop at nutrient
mobilization
we have all these other direct and
indirect mechan mechanisms of growth
promotion
um that mean that something like tribus
is not just a
we're not necessarily a all
jack-of-all-trades but it certainly is a
master of more than one
so you know the end idea here is that
yield should be looked at as a low
hanging fruit but there are many
other higher fruits that we should focus
on as we're doing
biostimulant development and
incorporating these products and
remembering what they're really good for
so that being said now we'll get into
some more concrete examples and
i look at biostimulants i think you can
divide it into basically three tiers
of products at least in today's day and
age so
fertilizers i look at as a tier one
biostimulant
microbial products i look at as a tier
two biostimulant
and biochemicals are what i would
consider the third tier of biostimulants
so let's get into that biosimulating
fertilizers i think the general idea
here is that they're relatively simple
to use
and the goal should be to kill two birds
with one stone
to put it bluntly so we can utilize
a combination of uh organic fertilizer
let's say that may be biostimulating
a good example of this is a hydrosate
product so they're vegetable based
hydraulsates
they're animal-based hydrosate products
like fish protein hydrosites
my company produces one of those and
these products are biostimulating
because they provide
nutrients which basically makes them a
fertilizer but in addition to that they
provide bio-stimulating compounds like
organic and amino acids
now to give one very simple example
that's relevant to
farmers around here there are
some hemp farms who have planted the
same genetic variety for
three or four years now and have had
different plant
responses different plant yields every
year because there are
some factors of the environment that can
control like hail or
cold temperatures maybe it's too wet to
harvest in the spring or two
or in the fall or too wet to plant in
the spring
one of the things that we've noticed
helps buffer
these variances that are out of our
control are applying something like an
amino acid fertilizer or a fertilizer
that contains amino acids
and when we do that what we can do is
supply the plant with some readily
available amino acid compounds
so we save a plant an energetic stuff
that it might not be able to do
given its environment uh again to use
the cold let's say a cold
rainy spring cold you know it's cloudy
outside plants not photosynthesizing
efficiently
it's too cold to effectively take up
nitrogen we don't want that crop to
stall
out in the ground so what we can do is
apply a foliar application of a
fertilizer let's say a fish hydrosite
that has these amino acid compounds
provides an immediate boost of building
blocks that the plant can use and
doesn't have to build itself
saves it that energetic step keeps crop
productivity high
and keeps the plant ready to you know
accelerate growth
when conditions improve on top of that
when we add
biostimulated fertilizers we're often
adding carbon
compounds to soil systems or to a root
system which of course encourages
microbial activity
that's another way that we can stimulate
plant growth
as well as improving soil quality which
of course has a sustainability
aspect to it as well that said
moving on to the second tier of
microbial inoculants you know i do like
to say that
fertilizers are tier one because they're
usually cheap they're usually pretty
easy to apply they can be applied in
conjunction with a lot of different
inputs
and microbial inoculants are not so much
different but they often do bring a
higher price tag
they can be a little bit more finicky to
deal with you need to be cognizant of
what microbes you're adding
and why and when and how
so that's why i bump them up onto a
second tier that being said you can use
any of these tiers
by themselves or you can use any of the
tiers in combination with each other
and frankly of course if you're trying
to be a truly biostimulant farmer
you'll want to use as many biostimulant
products as you can
that being said microbial inoculants
have come a long way over the last 20
years
instead of using our single isolated
strains
nowadays we use bacterial consortius my
company focuses primarily on bacteria
but i'll touch briefly on fungi and then
bio pesticides as well
but to start with you know we'll dive
into bacterial
products a little bit more and i think
bacteria products have a tremendous
amount of potential
again to be biosimulated help improve
crop quality and particularly flour and
fruit quality
nutritional content things that we
haven't necessarily focused on in the
past but
in relationship to something like
cannabis and in relationship
to the feed the world movement
sustainability movement
bacterial inoculants are starting to
show how important they really are
so things to keep in mind when you're
looking at inoculants
is something like an isolate versus a
consortium so
the old school of thought was we could
use a single isolated bacteria
to accomplish a single thing like let's
say as a fungicide
that works on occasion but it doesn't
work as well as it should
particularly in a real environment let's
say in a field environment
what we have figured out over the last
20 years and something that my company
is particularly fond of is
using bacterial consortius so we use a
team of bacteria
that help each other thrive and actually
accomplish more by working together with
each other
and together with the plant and that
plays directly into
plant growth promoting rhizobacteria or
pgprs
as important as the idea of a consortium
is the constituents of that consortia
so we don't want to necessarily just
throw a bunch of random microbes at a
plant and hope that some of them are
growth promoting
instead what we do is use new sequencing
techniques
like next generation sequencing where we
might look at a
specific unit of rrna like the 16s
subunit and do a lot of dna extraction
out of
rhizosphere soils for example
which requires tremendous amounts of
data analysis as well but
in the end we come up with a combination
of bacteria that
not only work well together not only are
naturally abundant
but are also things that the plant is
selecting for because of their growth
promoting abilities
so that differentiates a growth
promoting rhizobacteria or growth
promoting bacteria
from something like an effective
microorganism that might be very good at
cycling nutrients
but isn't necessarily something the
plant desires to have a very close
relationship with
fungi can kind of fall into that
category too of course there are a lot
of bacteria bacteria in that category
but
fungal inoculants are they have their
place they're tremendous
for the most part at promoting growth
during vegetative
phase of plant life but plant growth
promoting bacteria seem to play a bigger
role during fruit and flower ripening
and
the reproductive stage of life fungi
also need to be considered
in terms of their ability or their
potential to be parasitic to a plant
when we use free living microorganisms
or rhizobacteria
they're happy to live on their own they
don't necessarily need a plant around
the same can't be said for a
microbe like mycorrhizae mycorrhizal
requires that plant relationship of
course
and growers often use them or icy
growers often use them in
artificial environments so an
environment where they may be running a
tremendous amount of
supplemental phosphorus in that case
mycorrhizae might not actually be
providing a biostimulating benefit and
it might not actually be helping a plant
reach its genetic potential
instead it's uh requiring
a certain amount of energy from the
plant to survive you know so it's taking
carbon resources from that plant sugar
basically uh but in turn it's not
providing the benefit that it should be
which would be phosphorus mobilization
in most instances
just something to keep in mind i'm not
saying that mycorrhizae shouldn't be
used but it needs to be used with
caution
same thing goes for trichoderma it's a
tremendous nutrient cycler
it's a fairly effective bio-pesticide
but
it needs to be used with caution because
in high salinity environments it has
been shown to reduce yields
um you know the same
sort of caveats can be applied to
biopesticides where there are a lot of
biopesticides that work
tremendously indoors or in very specific
environments
but again this goes back to the idea
that we're looking for products for
biostimulants particularly
that can enhance a plant's genetic
potential and don't necessarily just
serve one purpose
we want these products that we're using
to serve a multitude of purposes
so we're seeing bio pesticides move in
that direction where we're actually
working with consortiums of growth
promoting bacteria
that simultaneously act as highly
functional bio-pesticides and that can
actually be one way they promote
there's a lot that you can go into on
that side of things and
there are a few leaders in the
bio-pesticide development side of the
industry like we're on bioinnovations
and bio
consortia producing very effective
products
uh and they're trying to accomplish more
than one thing with those
so let me know that being said i think
it's important to always put a face to
the name
you know the picture on the left here is
an example of a small
cannabis cutting only about a week or
less than two weeks old
with some pretty impressive root growth
of course it's not
anything out of the ordinary necessarily
but i think the root branching is
actually quite nice
and then the picture on the right is not
one of our pictures
uh but i think it does a gives a good
kind of
graphical representation of
what bacillus colonization of a root
surface looks like and that's one of the
most important things to consider with
these
biopesticides or with with growth
promoting bacteria
is rhizosphere competence and their
ability to colonize plant tissues
before anything else does because
ultimately when we're having all these
metabolomic
that are not necessarily just due to
nutrient acquisition
maybe in response to what the microbe is
doing on different plant tissues
and now that gets into i think the most
fun part of microbial product
development biostimulant product
development
nutrient mobilization is great but more
importantly
as it relates to phenolics we can look
at how microbes
when they're associated with different
soil types let's say
or in the case of grapes and wine with
different terrois
we can say and some groups of
researchers who spent a lot of time on
this
vocalic who put together this very nice
image of you know identifying different
bacterial communities that are
associated with different types of
californian grapes
during the first stage of the wine
making process which is like
when you're mashing grapes together and
making a great must
so the bacterial communities on those on
a great must is distinct between the
napa and sonoma and the central coast
valley
that's fascinating their focus was
primarily on fermentation but going a
little further
gilbert and others put together
a more comprehensive look at bacterial
communities that are associated with
different tissues
of the grapevine they're they're
they postulated that not only do
different bacterial communities
influence fermentation but actually
different microbes and microbiome of
different grape cultivars
is influencing that grapes flavor and
quality characteristics throughout its
entire life cycle
so whether it's bulk soil or rhizosphere
soil or bacteria that are found on
flowers or leaves or on the bark
all these microbes play a role in a
plant's response
they interact with the plant and they
elicit certain responses from the plant
that we can't get with just fertilizers
or pesticides alone
and that ultimately we'd love to be able
to
exploit and be able to utilize some of
our knowledge
that we find and that we have found that
we'll continue to find
on how these different bacterial
communities are associated with
different
terroirs let's say or flavors or quality
characteristics
and ultimately turn those into products
that we can use and replicate results
elsewhere
now that also takes us into the third
tier and that's biochemicals
so biochemicals are extremely complex
they're at a very early stage but this
is um
a part of the biostimulant uh industry
and
product development market that impello
is putting tremendous amounts of
our research and development resources
into so
real briefly because a lot of this
information is proprietary
and we're working hard to develop it but
we can't share too much right now
biochemicals that just says that we can
use some of these as immune
potentiators we can use some of these
signaling hormones or other
defense-related compounds that plants
naturally produce
to more or less trick a plant into doing
what we want it to
cannabis again is a great example of
this because it's a plant that's
devoting almost 30 percent
at times of its energetic resources
towards the production
of secondary metabolites cannabinoids
terpenes flavonoids solenoids
etc when we're farming a crop entirely
for those secondary metabolites not for
biomass but rather just for secondary
metabolite content
being able to increase the production of
those at
all uh is obviously highly valuable and
as you know you'll recall from the start
of this presentation
that boils down to the crops genetic
potential
and the environment so with these
biostimulant technologies and these
biochemicals
what we've been working on and this is
some of our field data
from a trial this year is utilizing
different combinations of let's say
microbial derived
biochemicals or plant derived
biochemicals or both
in exogenous applications to elicit
various specific responses from the
plant
this graph here shows that we have uh
we did a field trial in collaboration
with center edge genetics our genomics
company
that we work very closely with and more
or less what we found is that
metabolomic response
to this first iteration of biochemicals
we're creating
is highly dependent on the plant variety
at the bottom here on the x-axis you see
all these fl varieties those are
different
first light varieties from sunrise you
can see more or less
as denoted by the red
the treatment plants responded pretty
similarly
among all the first light varieties
to to the biochemical treatment that we
applied
whereas some non-first light varieties
that are genetically different
responded quite a bit differently and
what i can't show but
but will tell you is that if you break
down this is a graph of total terpenes
but if you break this down into
individual terpene constituents some
major minor terpenes
we actually had massively different
responses even between
varieties and especially between types
of
metabolites that we were looking at so
monoterpenes versus
sesquiterpenes etc all responded
uh very differently we can go even
further and i can
give another example to show how
complicated this biochemical problem is
but how much potential
there is in it and show that this is
some work we did with
colorado state university's proteomic
metabolomics facility
they have incredibly precise
capabilities there
for looking at metabolomic and proteomic
data and
so we ran a non-targeted
semi-quantitative
metabolite assay with them we did not
volatiles and non-volatiles
of course use different machinery for
both this is
one of the principal component analyses
graphs that we got back from the uplc
data
it's the same biostimulant applied at
different temporal points throughout the
plant's flowering
period so at the same concentration but
just applied
at different frequencies and different
time points we elicited completely
different metabolomic responses and this
is
a combination of over 2500 different
metabolites many of which we're still
annotating
because the system does not know the
taxonomy of the cannabis system that
we're using
so the point is just to show that even
with a little bit
of manipulation of a single biochemical
or of a single combination of multiple
biochemicals
we can elicit these massively different
responses from the plant
and obviously that's something we need
to dive deep into
particularly when considering the
pharmaceutical aspect of cannabis
but also when we're looking at improving
quality of other crops
grapes hops coffee anything with flavor
so lots of herbs etc
so that being said i hope the last 30
minutes gives you a better
understanding of how biostimulants can
be used to
influence a crop's genetic potential and
help maximize that potential
and how intricately related
crops genetics are to its environment
and really how we shouldn't look at
genetics and environment as two separate
pieces but rather as
how we can utilize both genetics and
environment develop products
to make the whole greater than the sum
of the parts
and i i think within all of that
hopefully you have a good understanding
or at least a good basis for
understanding that biostimulants
are certainly a sustainable way to
pursue
new technologies and agricultural inputs
appreciate all your time and i look
forward to speaking with any of you
individually if you have questions
please reach out to me directly via
email and i'll get back to you as soon
as i can
thanks very much